vous êtes allé faire un petit tour à l'
échec toujours oui c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire
pascal patron est professeur de
sommellerie ali thq c'est pourquoi nous
lui avons demandé de nous aider à
trouver le meilleur accessoire pour
conserver le vin après ouverture le vin
n'aime pas l'air si on laisse trop
longtemps au contact de l'air ça devient
du vinaigre 12 accessoires seront testés
sur des bouteilles de vin blanc de rouge
et de rouge nature 4 bouchon hermétique
si bouchons à pompe un système à gaz
inerte et un système pour le vin
effervescent d'en avoir et en je vais
goûter les vagues même faire ma fiche de
dégustation témoin les vins seront
goûtés le jour de l'ouverture
le jour 4 et après une semaine je sais
qu'on a un vin nature il se peut qu'il
soit carrément tourné pourquoi le vin
nature va moins bien réagir parce qu'il
ya moins de sulfite donc qui dit moines
sulfites moins préservé de l'oxygène
jour 1
on installe donc les systèmes à bouchon
on en profite pour tester l'étanchéité
qui dit air qui passe divin qui salent
d'heure et une petite goutte là qui
viennent de fuiter de l'autre côté mais
je pense que les toros épaules c'est pas
obligatoirement étanches les bouchons
trudeau oxo et le pôle texte avec filtre
de charbon ne laisse pas fuir le vingt
deuxième catégorie ce sont les bouchons
compan donc on va mettre le bouchon sur
la bouteille et on va pomper le bouchon
à pompe va peut-être laissé passer de
l'ère quotidiennement dans le protocole
j'ai décidé de les reporter tous les
jours pour voir s'il y avait une
différence versus si on le pompon jouera
et consorts sert quatre jours plus tard
on va faire cet essai là uniquement avec
le badge en plus du bouchon de base
épinac offre également dans son ensemble
un bouchon pour les vins effervescents
ricardo propose un beau champion le
système électrique de cuisine art ne
tient pas sur les bouteilles dévissable
vous chantiez apporte sur la bouteille
uniquement pour les bouchons de liège
bouteilles et bouchons des bouteilles
boucher à bouchon liège
vous avez confiance instant comme celui
là pour être honnête avec vous je les ai
déjà utilisé et oui j'ai confiance
c'est un mélange de d'azoté de dioxyde
de carbone et d'aragon un gaz inerte
plus lourd que l'air qui va venir se
déposer à la surface du va et on va
reboucher la bouteille avec sans bouchon
d'origine on se revoit dans une semaine
et on constatera ensemble au quatrième
jour pascal patron à goûter des vins
comme prévu et nous revoilà après une
semaine mais au bout d'une semaine c'est
donc le mouche ans d'origine qui serait
plus intéressant pourquoi pas utiliser
le bouchon d'origine il fonctionnait
bien
le bouchon d'origine vit sable ou de
liège faisait aussi partie du test
aucun bouchon hermétique n'a fait le
travail demandé ils ont tous laissé
passer l'air y compris celui qui avait
suscité le plus d'attentes le bouchon
charbon j'ai été un peu déçu voyons
maintenant les résultats avec les
bouchons à pompe la pompe cuisine art
malgré une charge complète a rendu l'âme
au bout de cinq jours nous en avons
testé une autre
même scénario si la pompe se brise et
qu'on peut plus l'utiliser au bout de
cinq jours c'est un peu un peu bizarre
eh bien tant jamais vraiment pris soin
et si en plus il charge puis pompe plus
bas ça sert pas à grand chose et en plus
d'être la pompe la plus chère du lot il
faut racheter un ensemble complet pour
avoir plus de deux bouchons starfrit tu
ne vends pas non plus de bouchons à
l'unité ce qui peut pratiquer le
bouchant pompe ricardo a agréablement
surpris qu tu parti avec à une énorme a
priori en me disant que je voyais pas
comment faisant plus que tout ça allait
ça allait conserver leva et au fur et à
mesure des jours qui passent m
j'ai été agréablement surprise que je me
dis il est autonome on n'a pas besoin
d'avoir une pompe à côté donc là on
passe aux vins nature ça c'est la grande
curiosité voir comment un vin sans
sulfites va tenir la route procure
encore du plaisir il ya le côté floral
qu'elle a le côté peace etc et là c'est
pas plus catastrophés que le vin avec se
fait finalement j'avoue que la cheville
j'ai même où je suis le premier surpris
d'ailleurs tous les vins nature ont
procuré ce plaisir à notre goûteurs sont
celui pompe et avec la cuisine art qui
ne fonctionnait plus et voyons comment
s'est comportée notre vin mousseux
après une semaine quoi c'est beau à
l'oeil c'est un corbeau alors tout cas
l'effervescence effectivement elle est
encore là au bout de huit jours
waouh voilà je suis surpris le gaz
inerte a une fois de plus convaincu
notre expert pour moi il est identique à
l'ouverture on peut l'utiliser jusqu'à
120 une fois pour pour 16 dollars et mis
à part le gaz les choix de notre expert
sont le vaincu 20 là j'avoue quand leurs
pompes en tout les jours m'a donné des
bons résultats
et puis le petit ricardo lakiss pompe
tout seul donc on a pas de risque
d'égarer la pompe mais il est préférable
garder la bouteille au réfrigérateur en
pompant tous les jours je pense que
c'est la solution la mieux à moins de
finir la bouteille le premier jour
[Musique]